alan greenspan the federal reserve
chairman coined the phrase a rational
exuberance to describe a phenomenon
where investors were pumping the price
of the market with little regard to
actual
underlying fundamentals fast forward
three decades or so we've reached
new levels of speculation meme coins are
worth more
than entire car companies a car company
who loses money
is worth more than all the other car
companies who make money combined
and yet alan greenspan said only a few
years ago that he sees no irrational
exuberance in today's market
you foresaw what was to occur in markets
uh
long before it actually happened when
you said irrational exuberance mr
chairman do you see similarities between
today's market and what you saw
back in the late 90s very little well
there you have it guys
no irrational exuberance i agree with
chairman greenbacks this isn't
irrational it's complete insanity you
guys are absolutely
killing it this is what i'm talking
about i stopped checking my truck's
wallet man
going
you guys are insane no we aren't insane
you're insane that's tick-tock sort of
the millennial version of the bloomberg
terminal
in this walking panic attack he's
talking about something called safe mode
a cryptocurrency that bills itself is
safely trying to get you to the moon for
anyone over 45 years old by the way
to the moon is slang for like your
investment made a lot of money
now this cryptocurrency launched a
little over a month ago but it's
already worth more than a billion
dollars in its market cap
actually i think at its peak it was
worth six billion dollars but don't
worry guys it's not a bubble
now in this video i'm going to be
addressing the newest in a long line of
meme coins like dogecoin but they're a
lot more
like safe moon that have popped up and
similar coins like hogecoin there's
safe mars safe galaxy safe star safe
anything
cosmic okay just know that and just
assume i'm applying this analysis to all
of them because
one they're gonna come and go but the
scheme is the same forever because yes
they're all slightly different but their
destiny is the same
and i'm gonna try to tell you why hola
mi gente and welcome back to the channel
this
is sean what's good what's good and
welcome back to investing with jax
welcome back everybody to a safe moon
price update on this video we are going
to talk about
dogecoin and we're also going to talk
about safe moon
all right moon boys listen i know you
guys are in the crypto space and it's
the wolf here
jb you know i'm bullish on crypto these
days i used to be a bear
now i'm a bull ah yes what could be
wrong with taking the advice of a
convicted felon
who got in trouble for yes hyping
garbage
but i think we all agree when jordan
belfort starts shilling it you know it's
bad now all these tokens we're going to
be discussing today are kind of
colloquially called
meme tokens they're structured not to be
useful necessarily as a currency but
rather to maximize
something called pumpamentals
papamentals are the feature of a coin
to generate hype virality buzz with
little regard to the usefulness
of the coin buzz for its own sake the
reason you name a coin after a meme it's
just a joke it's to
attract the hype which is why rather
than having a white paper which is
actually about something the whole
project is built around things like
to the moon or becoming millionaires or
more specifically in the case of safe
moon
one of the things they did was the first
things by the way was
confirmed a dogecoin trading pair
because what better way to pump a new
meme coin with an older meme coin and
then later in their white paper they
talk about
begin architecting the nft exchange as
well as video game integrations
like there's no real good reason for
video game integrations and nft
exchanges as your first move as a
currency
unless it's a publicity stunt a gimmick
to attract hype for its own sake now
another common pump of mental technique
is minting trillions of tokens
to keep your token below one cent
psychologically this makes people feel
like it's affordable and easy to own
whereas most people feel like
one bitcoin might be way outside their
budget what's a hundred
million times zero again i forgot the
other factor here is that it gets people
thinking about oh my gosh what if it
hits
a penny are you guys so this is safe
moon safe moon check it out look at this
current price right now
all right so let's say you invest only
like 30 right so you take that 30
times the current value of this coin
right now and you get about roughly 19
million coins
so let's say this thing goes up to about
just one cent your potential
almost 200 thousand dollars now what
this tick tock man doesn't tell you is
that in order for safe moon to reach one
penny
that would make the market cap of safe
moon six trillion dollars
triple the entire crypto market
so what sounds like super simple uh
would break
crypto now the other papa mentals are
things like they all say they're
deflationary currencies they're burning
tokens a rug pull is impossible there's
no way you possibly could get gypped off
by this coin guys
but one thing these all have in common
is that the only goal of the crypto
project is literally just to make the
price go up
literally in the name safe moon it's
like it's telling you it's a scam
look what do all get rich quick schemes
do they all say two things they say i'm
gonna get you rich
and this is definitely not a scam that's
what all scams have in common i'll get
you rich
fast and it's not a scam and safe mood
is literally telling you both of those
things
in one name it's genius like like
they're like we'll get you safely to the
moon don't worry this rocket will not
explode
we safe are to the
moon imagine for a second like the us
dollar the only reason people bought it
was literally just because everyone was
hyping the fact that if enough of us
bought dollars the value would go up
instead of like actually to buy things
and the whole value of the asset
is the price goes up isn't that a ponzi
scheme
i mean literally your whole thing is
like i gotta get as many people in
otherwise i'm gonna lose money if i
don't get more people in i can't get my
money out that's the whole thing
nothing actually behind it and at the
end of the day all these cryptos
have more in common than differences
which is why i wanted to address them
all at the same time like they quibble
about
our development team is you know more
open and they give amas
some are literal rug pulls right some
are just moon shots but
all of them have one thing in common
they're all just trying to get the price
to the moon it's a giant gamble there's
nothing serious about it
if you're doing it to gamble i have no
problem with you but as you're putting
a thousand dollars into safe moon ask
yourself would you put a thousand
dollars in the lottery tickets if that's
the kind of person you are
fine go with god but you know a lot of
people wouldn't do that but they feel
totally fine and like they're they're
missing out if they're not doing that
with safe moon but okay look
you're sitting there and uh maybe some
of you still aren't convinced so let me
try
one last ditch effort to try to convince
you that
maybe this is gambling and maybe a bad
gamble there's no rule right
that when people are talking about
something it's over when your grandma
starts talking about bitcoin
is it such a good buy probably not right
when everyone talks about something the
chances are the opportunity's mostly
over so
look at the people who are talking about
safe moon hyping it to the moon right
and ask yourself
is this a bubble jake paul lance stewart
ben phillips you know icons of financial
advice
okay they don't understand just let him
go dude how funny would it be
if that's what convinced people they're
like hey a coin that launched
a month ago being worth a billion
dollars i wasn't on board with it being
a scam but now that i know jake paul is
involved
i'm out what if that's what got him like
literally
jake paul being involved you're like
well i was in till that moment he got me
there
i hope you enjoyed the video diving into
these cryptos is fun for me
uh let me know if you get anything out
of it am i preaching to the choir here
is everyone who like actually likes
these things like no no no no no like
fud foot foot
either way whether you're invested in
dogecoin safe moon meme coins whatever
there's one coin one stock you can
always pump
costs nothing pump zilla guys to the
moon
like and subscribe it's free respect the
pup
and uh i'll see you guys in the next one
i know what you need
this ain't what it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost me wake up and
smell the coffee